[Music]
hey what is up everybody its Anna Mack
here for anime All Pro and welcome to
another episode of crazy anime theories
that actually make sense
[Music]
this is a series in which we take a look
at some of the craziest anime fan
theories out there in order to determine
whether any of them could possibly or at
least plausibly be true in this episode
I'll be arguing that the seven deadly
sins and Code Geass actually take place
in the same fictional universe and what
the heck since we're already going that
deep into the rabbit hole I'm gonna
throw in one more anime and I'm going to
say that not only do seventh of these
sins and Code Geass take place in the
same universe but Gurren Lagann another
anime that I love also takes place
inside that same fictional universe
that's right I'm gonna be arguing that
meliodas Lelouch and camina all exist
within one single universe and even
though this might be too much manliness
for our puny minds to even handle I'm
gonna give it a shot
as always these crazy theory videos are
made for fun and of course I don't
expect theories like these to ever be
confirmed officially after all we're
talking about three series that are made
by three different creators so learnt
the odds of all three of them coming
together and saying yeah that one random
guy on YouTube was totally right but no
matter what I say I'm sure we're still
gonna get a bunch of triggered comments
down below so bring it on
if you think that this is a fun concept
for a video series you can do the whole
like and subscribe thing and if you want
to give me suggestions for crazy anime
theories that I can cover in the future
be sure to follow us on Twitter and
Instagram
at anime up lore and reply to the linked
thread you can find the direct link to
the relevant thread in the description
and also down in the pinned comment and
now ladies and gentlemen let's get into
it
now the first obvious connection between
the seven deadly sins and Code Geass is
of course Britannia in our own world
Britannia was the name that the ancient
Romans used for Great Britain and later
for their own province of Britannia
after they conquered parts of the island
around the year 43 AD the seven deadly
sins story takes place in a land known
as Britannia that looks very much like
Great Britain and Ireland and in code
geass Japan is invaded by the Holy
Britannian Empire a global superpower
that originated in Great Britain
although in the world of code
yes Rome never succeeded in colonizing
Britain so the Britons developed as a
unique and independent people before
eventually forming the holy Britannian
Empire and since Great Britain plays a
major role in both of these series the
lore and mythology of Britain including
Arthurian legend plays a crucial part in
both code geass and the seven deadly
sins many character names and the names
of cities and kingdoms and the seven
deadly sins come directly from Arthurian
legend from Merlin Melly Otis Eskin or
gopher and bond to Arthur Pendragon the
kingdom of Camelot and the legendary
sword Excalibur in Code Geass we also
find many direct references to Arthurian
legend from the name of the Britannia
imperial capital which is Pendragon to
suzaku's Knightmare frame Lancelot and
of course to the knights of the round a
reference to the knights of the round
table in Arthurian legend now the Normie
explanation for these commonalities
would be that both of these series were
independently inspired by the history of
Great Britain and by Arthurian legend so
that is the only reason why they have so
many things in common but a true man of
culture knows that the real reason why
the seven deadly sins and Code Geass
have so many things in common is because
they take place in the same world they
just happen to take place at different
points in that world's history to be
brief the seven deadly sins story is
taking place in the ancient history of
that world thousands of years before the
events of Code Geass Wow Code Geass is
taking place at a time that is much
closer to our own modern world although
their technology is even more advanced
than ours but then the question is even
if Code Geass and seven deadly sins are
separated by thousands of years how is
it possible that a code geass we don't
see more remnants of the seven deadly
sins world well in terms of physical
evidence like architecture the Britannia
of code geass actually lost Great
Britain to Napoleon in the early 1800s
and so the Britannia were forced to
relocate to North America so because the
story takes place pretty much entirely
outside of Great Britain it is only
natural that we never see
ruins of Camelot or the ruins of Leona's
in the actual story but then what about
the characters we know that many of the
characters in the seven deadly sins seem
to be immortal or at least capable of
living for thousands of years so why
don't we see any of them even mentioned
in code geass the intro sequence that we
can see at the beginning of every
episode of the seven deadly sins anime
might give us an explanation the
narrator tells us that this is a tale
from ancient times when the human and
non-human worlds had not yet split the
holy wars have been repeating themselves
throughout ancient Britannia history and
no one seemed to know why they broke out
or how to stop them but now of course
meliodas and the seven deadly sins are
attempting to stop the war and suffering
for good this intro implies that at some
point in the future the human realm is
likely going to be separated from the
other realms perhaps the only way to
stop these holy wars from occurring in
the future will be to use incredibly
powerful magic to seal away the
different clans within their own
separate realms where they can all exist
peacefully without killing each other so
perhaps the reason why we don't see the
Giants or the fairies or the demons in
Code Geass is because they all now exist
in completely separate realms even
though they once existed in the same
world many years ago however even though
the world of code geass features
futuristic technology like nightmare
frames there is still something very
similar to magic in this world and that
is of course the power of Geass Geass
powers are obviously not the same as the
magical abilities that we see in the
seven deadly sins but there are striking
similarities between certain magical
spells in seven deadly sins and certain
Geass powers for example we know that
immortality exists in the seven deadly
sins and it is possessed in different
ways by characters like Bond who drank
from the Fountain of Youth and meliodas
who was cursed to keep coming back to
life and of course in Code Geass
a being who obtains code also becomes
effectively immortal much like bond a
person with code will not age and their
wounds
he'll instantly the very origin of the
word Geass comes from Irish mythology so
again the British Isles connection and
in Irish mythology a Geass can be both a
curse and a blessing and of course we
have both curses and blessings in the
seven deadly sins more comparisons
between Geass powers and seven deadly
sins abilities include Marianne's Geass
which allows her to possess the body of
someone else and the ability of the
goddess clan to possess the bodies of
other creatures Lelouch is Geass and
also the Geass of Clara LAN Franck from
the Asda reflection manga allows them to
control the bodies of other people in
various ways and of course cool socks
ability resonant allows him to do a
similar thing to arthur emperor charles
deus allows him to rewrite the memories
of other people and of course Golder and
the original goal have the ability
called invasion which can rewrite and
manipulate memories Lorenzo Ilsa resi
from the Renia of the darkness manga has
a Geass power that allows him to create
illusions and similar powers have been
demonstrated in the seven deadly sins as
well for example by the demon Poirot Nia
and so on and so on another important
thing that we know about the world of
Code Geass
is that there once existed on ancient
civilization called the Ragnar s they
are referred to as the rock nourished by
Emperor Charles in Episode one of the
anime if you watch it and sub because
they took it out in the dubbed version
and these Ragnar s are the civilization
which is believed to have constructed
the eight mysterious thought elevators
located throughout the world and they
are also believed to have constructed
the collective human unconsciousness
which resides in seas world and within
which all human consciousnesses are
united after death the thought elevator
and seized world are directly linked to
Geass powers so it is clear that the
ancient civilization that constructed
them was extremely advanced in their
ability to produce and manipulate both
technology and magic in the form of
Geass power so what if this ancient
civilization in code geass these
Regnerus were actually the ancient
Wizards and druids from the seven deadly
sins
sometime after the events of the seven
deadly sins
this civilization of wizards or druids
or whatever they are decided it the only
way to stop the holy war and infighting
between the demons and the goddesses is
to separate the realms and they
succeeded in separating the realms
through the use of the thought elevators
we still don't actually know the exact
purpose and function of the thought
elevators within the world of Code Geass
so the idea of them being used to
separate different realms of existence
isn't too far-fetched especially when we
considered the amount of power that the
thought elevators and seized world have
already been shown to possess but I can
already hear some of you saying no way
the type of magic in seven deadly sins
is way different than Geass power and
Code Geass it's a completely different
power system completely different
characters you're crazy man then how
about this maybe the world of the seven
deadly sins is not the ancient history
of the world of Code Geass maybe it is
the mythology of the world of Code Geass
the characters in the seven deadly sins
may never have actually existed in the
world of cocky-ass just like King Arthur
and Merlin may never have really existed
in our own world but it is this
mythology that inspired the Arthurian
legends of the holy Britannian Empire so
sometime during the Middle Ages in the
Code Geass world they began telling the
stories of the seven deadly sins in the
same way that we tell the stories of
King Arthur and the knights of the round
table in our own world and how did these
mythical stories come about in the first
place while they were directly inspired
by Geass powers and the advanced ancient
civilization that existed long before
the current events in Code Geass but
because so many centuries have passed
since the ancient civilization which
could use incredible magical powers
known as EOS existed the truth was
slowly lost as people told and retold
these magical stories from generation to
generation and what remained was a
fantastical myth about meliodas Merlin
the Druids the demons and the world of
the seven deadly sins all of this
mythology is rooted in Geass
our a magical ability that actually
exists in their world but as thousands
of years past the core of the story
changed as it was passed down from one
person to another person kind of like a
game of broken telephone and so the
advanced ancient civilization that had
mastered the use of Geass eventually
became a medieval fantasy adventure
about demons goddesses fairies Giants
and wizards I mean the way that
Elizabeth's right eye changes when she
uses her powers is a perfect example of
this when I first saw her ability I
couldn't help but be reminded of Geass
power and even though the color and the
shape of the symbol in her eye differs
from the eye of someone using Geass
the similarity is still pretty striking
so it would make perfect sense if the
story of Elizabeth and the power of the
goddesses was based on someone using
Geass power in real life but the
specific details like the color of the
eye and the specific shape of the symbol
in the eye changed as the story of this
mysterious power was told and retold
from generation to generation but wait
there's more since we're already
connecting the worlds of two completely
different series why don't we just go
completely nuts and add a third in the
final episode of the Code Geass OVA
called Akito the exiled one of the main
characters in that story layla comes
face to face with a strange being and
this being calls itself the
representative of the collective
consciousness of the universe this being
is also sometimes called the caretaker
of space-time and this being is clearly
directly connected to the us power
because she has the Geass symbol on her
neck and she says to layla that she
believes that human beings should not be
allowed to use Geass power because it is
too dangerous to allow Geass to fall
into the hands of humans she even says
that the idea of humans misusing Hijaz
is so dangerous that they must be
stopped even at the price of the entire
human race going extinct
however the being then adds that she
thinks Leila may actually be worthy of
her Geass power and that Leila may end
up changing her mind about humans after
all personally I believe that this
mysterious being calling itself the
caretaker of space-time is a
manifestation of the collective human
consciousness which exists inside sees
world and which durog nur is created by
initiating the first Ragnarok connection
which essentially transferred their own
consciousnesses into the collective
consciousness or unconsciousness
whichever way you want to put it
although the caretaker of space-time is
clearly a conscious being so rather than
saying unconsciousness
I think collective consciousness seems
like the more appropriate term at any
rate we know that the ultimate plan of
Emperor Charles at the end of our to
seems to be to create a second Ragnarok
connection in order to eliminate
individuality and lies by uniting the
currently living human beings with the
collective consciousness so basically
the ragnar has transferred their own
consciousness into the collective
consciousness during the first Ragnarok
and now Charles wants to repeat that
process with everyone who is still alive
today by initiating a second Ragnarok
connection and all of this should sound
very familiar to well every fan of
Evangelion with the human
instrumentality project but also to fans
of tengan Toppa Gurren Lagann in the
world of Gurren Lagann the anti spirals
are a species of humanoid beings who
decided to trap themselves in a state of
suspended animation and get rid of their
own individuality by forming a
collective consciousness the reason they
did this is because they wanted to stop
their own evolution as they believed
that creatures who use spiral powers
such as humans and other similar species
could not be trusted with spiral power
in Gurren Lagann spiral power is the
ability to evolve and keep getting
stronger throughout the generation and
it is possessed by all creatures who
have DNA with the spiral double helix
structure however in Gurren Lagann
spiral power goes beyond merely the
concept of evolution in many ways it is
a supernatural ability that allows those
who use it to reshape matter and even
generate new matter out of nothing and
while we're on the topic of that it
actually reminds me of s canora's
ability from the seven deadly sins
ESCA NORs ability sunshine allows us can
order to grow to an immense height and
an immense weight during the day and
then shrink into a very tiny man at
night the anti spirals were once
themselves spiral power based creatures
but when they realize that spiral power
has infinite
potential to keep changing and evolving
they concluded that if the power became
overused and misused it could lead to
the destruction of the entire universe
as a result they decided to stop their
own evolution form a collective
consciousness and suppress other species
who were using spiral power now doesn't
the anti spiral collective consciousness
from Gurren Lagann sound a lot like the
representative of collective
consciousness from cold Geass the
representative also did not trust humans
with Geass power just like the anti
spirals did not trust humans with spiral
power and both sides are prepared to
exterminate the entire human race if
that is what is required for the
well-being of the universe so what if
the true identity of the anti spirals is
the collective consciousness from Code
Geass what if the anti spirals are the
ancient Rogner s and what if sometime in
the very distant future humans used and
manipulated Geass power in such a way
that it evolved and became what we know
as spiral power at that point the ragnar
s aka dnt spirals decided to act and
suppress the humans before they used
Geass power aka spiral power to destroy
the universe interestingly enough in
Gurren Lagann the very first villains we
meet are creatures known as beast men
artificially created beings who have
mixed animal and human DNA because they
are artificially created they did not
evolve naturally so they do not possess
spiral power and for this reason they
were used to keep the humans who possess
spiral power in check and we know that
in the seven deadly sins there are
creatures known as beast men - they are
animal and human hybrids like zhivago
who were feared by humans and because
they were so feared by humans they were
also persecuted by them it is as if the
ancient mythology about the seven deadly
sins and the beast men from those
stories inspired the creation of the
artificial beast men in the distant
future and these new beast men were
meant to be feared by humans just as the
ancient beasts men once were and all of
this means that the seven deadly sins
Code Geass and Gurren Lagann all take
place in the same world but at very
different times the story of the seven
deadly sins as either the ancient
history or the mythology of this
world the story of Code Geass takes
place closer to our own modern time
except they clearly have more advanced
technology than we do right now and the
story of Gurren Lagann takes place in
the very distant future after the power
of Geass evolves into spiral power and
the collective consciousness from Code
Geass also known as the anti spirals in
Gurren Lagann finally make their move to
stop humans and other similar creatures
from abusing this power and destroying
the whole universe in the process so let
me know what you guys think how crazy is
this theory on a scale from zero to
petal goose and what other crazy anime
theories that actually make sense should
I cover in the future be sure to give me
your suggestions on Twitter and
Instagram by replying to the relevant
thread link is in the description and in
the pinned comment if you enjoy this
type of video let me know by leaving a
like and if you're new to the channel
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell as always thank you
all so much for watching this video was
quite a journey
for all of us I think and until next
time see us bass cowboys
[Music]